militaires sur matin vous vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure alors ans a
encore été agressé au couteau dans le
métro est ce que c'est pas le signe de
l'inefficacité de cette opération en
tous les cas c'est la question qu'on
vous pose aujourd'hui sur le figaro dans
le sur lefigaro.fr il pouvait continuer
à y répondre et réguler c'est difficile
parce que je crois que ces jeunes
utilisaient tout à l'heure ses terres
qu'il ya aussi difficile de remettre en
question l'opération de sentinelle la
présence militaire dans les rues parce
que bon on va me parler de sa cause en
politique est un problème de 2 encore
une fois on revient cité de peur et de
rassurance quoi j'ai quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui si on supprime l opération
sentinel telle qu'elle est ce serait une
catastrophe
donc après c'est la mobilisation des
moyens je crois que le parallèle avec la
politique de proximité n'est pas n'est
pas juste je crois que c'est pas quelque
chose qui qu'ils soient comparables
je crois que d'une part il ya des
individus ça a été dit aussi qu'ils sont
militaires des hommes qui sont des
hommes et les femmes qui s'engagent dans
l'armée pas pour ça et que cette
opération est la plus répandue à une
dimension politique une dimension
militaire
et puis après encore une fois je suis
désolé de revenir à ça mais c'est des
gens qui ont besoin de tourner et qui
ont besoin de bouger c'est que
aujourd'hui l'armée comme la police a
besoin d'hommes et d'argent